la question est éternelle de savoir qui
fut premier l'oeuf ou la poule
je crains que la question reste
éternellement sans réponse et rassurez
vous on ne va pas essayer aujourd'hui
ils répondent et on va partir sur deux
certitudes
la première certitude que nous
partageons tous c'est que les poules
fondées ça je crois qu'il ya pas de
contestation la deuxième certitude m'a
valu quelques rires c'est que les zones
les poules sont meilleurs que les autres
alors généralement neri reçoit un peu
condescendant
je peux m'amuser mon pauvre vieux bon ça
va pas trop gaga jusqu'au jour où j'ai
rencontré claude aubert qui est un
ingénieur agronome spécialiste de
nutrition et j'ai eu plaisir de passer
une semaine avec lui ses membres passent
une semaine avec quelqu'un on raconte un
petit peu ces bêtises quotidienne et
j'ai pas manqué de lui dire que les uns
de mes poules tu sais sont meilleurs que
les autres accueils condescendant sauf
que une semaine après qu'on se soit
quitter je reçois un mail de claude
aubert qui me vila écoute tu sais
j'avais raison j'avais raison
une vie je vienne faire une étude pour
une société italienne peu importe qui
m'a demandé de faire des comparatifs
entre entre les eux alors j'ai pris
trois catégories j'ai pris la poule
conventionnelle la poule conventionnelle
ça vous parle d'un pont promotionnelles
elle est installée là pour toute sa vie
une feuille a4 1 est dans un schéma
paulin et puis elle fait des oeufs puis
quand tu vas finir de le passer à la
casserole fait une vie super ça c'est la
poule correctionnel il ya la poule bio
c'est vachement mieux un pôle bio elle a
droit elle 1 5 mètre carré alors pour
ceux qui n'ont jamais vu de poule
poule sur cinq mètres carrés au bout
d'une semaine mais reste plus rien c'est
le désert à la gratte et a tout bouffé
il ya rigoureusement plus rien mais elle
est bio et puis il ya il ya la poule en
libre parcours poule de luxe et la peine
je leur explique tous les jours qu elles
sont des poules de luxe des poules au
libre parcours et celle là elles ont ils
ont de l'herbe a bouffé l oms peuvent
courir après des sauterelles peuvent se
faire les gambettes et c'est pour un peu
moins donc c'est pas terrible c'est pas
intéressant économiquement mais et
gustativement et j'ai fait un comparatif
mais dit-il entre les trois et ô
surprise il ya plus d'écart entre le
plan nutritionnel je parle
nutritionnelle entre la poule 2 libre
parcours et la poule bio qu'entre la
poule bio la poule promotionnelles ça
m'a quand même sérieusement questionner
du coup je me suis lancé dans des
petites enquêtes qui m'ont amené à
découvrir un certain nombre de choses je
vais vous en faire partager quatre
premiers points
on n'a pas trop le temps je veux pas
vous laisser deviner mais je vais vous
poser la question est ce que vous savez
combien de km parcours un produit entre
l'endroit où il est produit et votre
assiette là vous avez le consommer
rapidement vous avez les 6000 km 6000 km
si on tient compte de l'ensemble des
ingrédients qui viennent parfois à issia
duris et terrasse il ya des choses c'est
du chocolat l'emballage si bien km ça
c'est la moyenne deuxième point que se
passe-t-il si on coupe le robinet du
pétrole
alors d'abord ça arrivera un jour puis
ensuite la folie humaine n'ayant pas de
limite en ce moment on a quelques
exemples intéressants
robin et le pétrole qui se coupe c'est
pas forcément pour très très longtemps
trois jours vous avez à bouffer pour
trois jours dans le système de
distribution actuel points après c'est
fini il n'y a plus rien ça fonctionne
pas d'accord un autre point troisième
qui a été mis en avant par le professeur
joyeux c'est si vous mangez des pêches
et que vous avez l'intention d'un gérer
en même temps que la pêche autant de
nutriments dans les pêches des années 50
il faudrait que vous mangiez 52 le
progrès est en marche et dernier point
on va revenir sur claude aubert que
robert lui il a proposé le point de
repère suivant si vous cueillez un fruit
ou un légume à maturité et que vous lui
donniez une valeur nutritionnelle de
sang à maturité vous le payez sans
lendemain 90 surlendemain 80 et ça va
descendre ainsi de suite à la fin de la
semaine si vous êtes à 20 c'est déjà pas
mal
alors vous imaginez ce que vous avez
dans votre assiette si le fruit ou le
légume il a été cueilli n'ont pas la
maturité mais suffisamment pas mûre pour
supporter le voyage
il vous reste un gros second plus rien
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on jette par
la fenêtre on dit toute façon on bouffe
tellement mal que on comprend pourquoi
on a un certain nombre de maladies dues
à des carences passe en france la
réponse elle est tellement simple comme
très souvent quand on a des questions
compliquées
les réponses sont terriblement simple
réponse c'est très simple c'est manger
local
manger local alors
ça a immédiatement vu ce qu'on vient de
dire un certain nombre de vertus
1 forcément si on ne fait plus de 6000
kilomètres on va consommer moins
d'énergies fossiles
on va donc émettre moins de co2 - des
gaz à effet de serre
donc économiquement c'est intéressant
plus en plus on va faire plaisir à nous
à nos voisins producteurs c'est déjà pas
mal
et puis très égoïstement pour soi on va
avoir des produits une qualité
nutritionnelle
quand même nettement plus intéressante
est ce qu est vexant dans cette affaire
c'est de réaliser que il ya un siècle
à la fin du 19ème toutes les communes de
france était autosuffisante soit plan
alimentaire y compris paris y compris
paris qui était particulièrement bien
nourries par sa couronne de maraîchers
qui en plus travailler en permaculture
sanou de sujet on va pas développer soi
si on m'invite je vous expliquerai mais
c'est pas franchement le sujet du jour
donc toutes les communes de france était
autosuffisante
pourquoi sommes nous pas capables de
faire la même chose
c'est une question que s'est posée une
petite ville du nord de l'angleterre qui
s'appelle tonnes morden à la faim en
2008 ville industrielle en plein déclin
passé de 45 mille habitants à 15 milles
taux de chômage 30% délinquance
explosive il ya des femmes dans ce genre
de choses sauf qu'il ya souvent des
femmes je peux vous savez c'est comme ça
et il ya des femmes qui se sont réunis
en angleterre on se réunit au pub et
open est joli mais on va pas rester
comme ça c'est pas possible
et elles ont décidé de se réapproprier
leur alimentation et elles sont parties
une action très simple très petites
actions c'était de cultiver les
parcelles qui étaient disponibles dans
l'espace public de la ville et de mettre
un petit panneau dessus nourriture à
partager servez-vous c'est gratuit et
elles sont parties sur une utopie qui
est la suivante c'est de dire en 2008 en
2018 on sera autosuffisant sur le plan
alimentaire sur un rayon de 50 miles
trois ans après trois ans après elle
était à 80 3% alors mince quand même si
au nord de l'angleterre on est capable
d'atteindre en trois ans une
autosuffisance alimentaire 83%
peut-être que dans le sud-ouest de la
france on devrait pouvoir arriver à la
même chose c'est ce que je me suis dit
et en 2013 j'ai lancé avec d'autres
associations sur albi les incroyables
comme et si vous êtes peut-être déjà
entendu parler de ça ou pas mme donc le
principe est celui qu'on vient de dire
sur thônes morden au cultive les
parcelles privées ou publiques et on met
un panneau dessus nourriture à partager
servez-vous c'est gratuit alors pour
être très sincère sa part été forcément
très facile tout de suite avec la ville
d'albi quand vous avez une ville qui est
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco qui est très fier de ses quatre
fleurs et vous avez des zozos qui
viennent planter des tomates qui
forcément un jour flétrissent et puis
qu'il ya plein de paille sur les
trottoirs et les carrefours de la ville
ce n'était pas le grand bonheur bon ça a
mal démarré mais après ça on s'est
apprivoisés tellement bien apprivoisé
que
en janvier 2015 la ville a signé avec
nous les incroyables comestibles une
convention s'engageant à l'horizon 2020
c'est la fin de la mandature vers
l'autosuffisance alimentaire dans un
rayon de 50 km alors on n'est pas quand
même tout à fait complètement cinglé on
s'imagine pas que c'est en plantant
trois pieds de tomates sur les plates
bandes de la ville ou sur les carrefours
les ronds-points et c'est qu'on va
nourrir une agglomération de 80000
habitants
non non on a monté une stratégie avec
les acteurs locaux que nous impliquons
dans cette démarche et nous avons
entrepris d'agir sur quatre points
quatre points que sont la production la
transformation transformation
conservation la distribution et la
formation éducation
on va commencer par le quatrième
pourquoi formation éducation parce que
si on fait plein de choses pour produire
plein de choses sur place mais que nos
concitoyens continuent à aller acheter
les derricks aux verts qui viennent du
kenya ou des tomates qui viennent du fin
fond de l'andalousie
ça n'a pas servi à grand chose donc
cette étape d'éducation nous la menons
avec trois acteurs principaux les
services techniques de la ville et les
élus nous les incroyables comestibles et
le personnel pédagogique des du primaire
là on travaille avec les enfants pour
leur réapprendre à mettre les mains dans
la terre où leur apprendre un travail
qui est vraiment passionnant à faire
avec les enfants vous connaissez tous
cette anecdote parce qu'elle a été
largement répandue on demande à des
enfants petits de représenter un poisson
il vous faut un parallélépipède
rectangle
c'est un petit peu dommage et moi ce que
j'ai pu constater aussi c'est qu'il y
avait un gros travail à faire avec les
enfants et pas uniquement avec les
enfants des quartiers comme on dit
sur d'où viennent les fruits et légumes
par exemple pour tous ces mômes des
pommes qu'on trouve dans les arbres sont
des projectiles
les pommes qui se mange mange pas ce qui
se mange c'est ce qui est dans des
barquettes en gms c'est pas une blague
c'est vraiment la réalité on en est là
moi je sais que j'ai essayé pendant un
temps de travailler avec les restos du
coeur et j'étais vraiment triste de voir
que les légumes ça ne les intéresse pas
beaucoup eu nombre de nos contemporains
qui ne savent pas par quel bout ça
s'attrape un poireau c c'est un vrai
sujet donc ça on règle ça à la base on
règle ça on se cogne à ce problème à la
base avec les enfants et on espère que
ça va remonter avec les parents c'est en
cours pendant que je vous parle en
octobre 2015 c'est une action qui est
lancé on n'est plus dans le projet s'est
lancé deuxième point c'est la
distribution et distribution là aussi
suffit pas de produire il faut
distribuer deux axes premières acc c'est
avec les les marchés locaux qui sont pas
terribles dans le pa lantagne il y en a
un très bien réellement mais en albi
c'est pas un florissant c'est pas vivant
et je pense que nous pouvons grandement
les améliorer pour qu'il ya à la fois
plus de producteurs et s'il ya plus de
producteurs il y aura plus d'acheteurs
pour acheter ça et en même temps comme
malheureusement on va pas changer du
jour au lendemain les habitudes de nos
contemporains de nos concitoyens de vous
pas de moi parce que j'ai déjà changé
mais je pense pas que vous avez tous
changés taille avons fait encore partie
de ceux qui à 95% à chaque clan
nourriture en grande distribution et a
donc on a été voir la grande
distribution et on est en train là de
signer une convention avec les trois
acteurs principaux sur albi pour que
tous les ans il achète plus de produits
locaux sans pour autant s'il vous plaît
mais c'est une étrangler les producteurs
locaux parce qu'ils savent très bien
faire
et ça c'est le deuxième point qui est en
train de fonctionner le troisième point
qui était mon second à savoir
transformer conserver tout le monde
c'est parce qu'on a toujours entendu
parler surtout ici on n'est pas très
loin de marmande un troisième semaine du
mois d'août on jette des camions entiers
de tomates sur la route c'est quand même
assez scandaleux on va pas amener des
personnes à produire pour que aux gets
sens il n'y a pas beaucoup de
transformations mental on va les aider
les accompagner pour qu'il y ait des la
transformation et la conservation qui se
met en place on a déjà un acteur qui
nous suit c'est la cuisine centrale
d'albi qui est tous les jours sur
plusieurs milliers de repas et qui est
très intéressé par le fait de s'équiper
en personnel et en matériel pour
conserver transformé et le premier point
c'est la production ce point là est déjà
en train de bouger puisque la mairie
achète 70 hectares de terres maraîchères
il y en a dix qui sont déjà acquis 60
qui sont gelés qui vont l'être et sur
ses dix hectares nous avons déjà
installé de nouveaux marchés et nous
sommes je suis nous sommes en train d'en
installer un troisième et lorsqu ils
sont tous en place ils ont ont droit en
plus à une maison pour vendre sur place
leur leurs produits et en même temps je
passe une convention avec le lycée
agricole de fonlabour qui est
propriétaire de trois ans trois fermes
sur le tarn où il produit surtout les
céréales et qui vont convertir chaque
année du céréalier ans maraîcher
cette convention est en train d'être
signés à la condition que nous écoulons
leur production sur les marchés et dans
la grande distribution c'est concret
c'est en cours c'est parti d'une utopie
qui est venu l'angleterre jusqu'à moi et
que j'ai répercuter sur les trottoirs de
la ville en foutant de la paille partout
et aujourd'hui ça fonctionne ça veut
dire que ces petites actions peuvent
entrer dans le concret pour moi qui suis
un modeste parmi les modestes et pour
vous ça peut être concret demain et ça
me donne l'occasion de conclure avec
cette légende amérindienne qui a été
rendu célèbre par pierre abry pierre
rabhi celle du colibri
la forêt est en feu l'incendié fait rage
tous les animaux foutent le camp
chassé par l' incendie sauf le petit
colibri le petit colibri fait la navette
entre la rivière et l'incendié il jette
ça coûte d'eau sur l'incendié
ils étaient tous qu'ils regardent du
dénommé va pas non c'est pas avec ça que
tu va éteindre un incendie colibri dit
et je sais mais je fais ma part c'est
mon cas ça peut être le vôtre